i want to take you live to pictures
coming to us
via nasa of the air force base in
vandenberg
in california where you can see spacex's
falcon 9 rocket which
is about to launch where the u.s
european sentinel
6 michael freila ocean observing
satellite and that's designed to extend
the
30 years of study on the ocean
floors it will be the first of two
identical satellites that will monitor
over
launched five years apart which will
monitor uh increases in sea levels and
really help to
monitor and combat uh climate change
all over the world it's going to have a
lot of uk
expertise on board that satellite as
well with the
met office and uh the national
oceanography center
also wanting to analyze that data let's
have a listen in now
as we expect the countdown to take off
michael freilick continuing a legacy of
ocean observation and international
collaboration
to benefit all humanity
m1d propulsion is nominally
foreign
vehicle is supersonic
so whilst we're watching those amazing
pictures
live of that rocket launching from
vandenberg
in california let's bring in dr john
sidorn from the
uh head of ocean forecasting research
and development
at the met office absolutely incredible
pictures both from earth looking up at
that
falcon 9 and from the rocket looking
back down
to earth always an amazing spectacle
whenever spacex launches something into
space but very exciting from a science
perspective
as well doctor yeah hello it's great to
see those pictures
it is very exciting for us because
clearly
this is a real a real step forward for
us in getting that reference mission
back up in the sky well i'm hoping it's
up in the sky we haven't quite seen it
go yet but
uh yeah very exciting for us so why does
this launch that we're watching
happen over the seas of california
matter to us watching
from here in the uk aside obviously from
being absolutely amazing pictures
so there are a number of altimeters uh
satellites that measure the the sea
level
uh up at the moment but the reference
mission which is the one that
provides the the really high fidelity
the high accuracy data that we really
need to
to baseline the rest of the the
observations uh is the
the the json uh series of satellites is
is coming to end of life so this ensures
that we get that continuity into the
future
into 2030. so it really makes sure that
what we're doing now
can be continued but also continued with
with with improved accuracy and
improved information so just give us a
little sense of the amount of work
that's gone into today because i
understand the satellite is only the
size of a small
4x4 car but it's going to orbit around
the earth around 830 miles above the
planet
and will do so for many years to come
well first of all i'm not a satellite
if you look at that thing it's it's
about the size of the car as you say but
the precision
sensors on it that are required to
measure the sort of the the centimeter
level
uh of the sea level in amongst all the
waves you know the waves which could be
20 meters
uh requires not only good sensors to
measure the the sea level but
the positioning needs to be pretty much
millimeter accurate the
the ability to uh position the at
satellite requires
massive amounts of technology so it's
really impressive what these
these guys are doing and a continuation
of important studies because of course
we have seen haven't we the
concerns about climate change increasing
in recent years not least with the
threat from flooding
uh becoming more serious here in the uk
yeah so
obviously if we if we even increase the
the sea level a small amount uh
our flood defenses are designed around
us or the present day
uh or at least the the recent flood
defensive design around the present day
uh sea level so if that increases that
will increase the frequency of
over topping and flood events around our
coastal cities and that's a that's a key
problem and of course we don't really
fully understand at the moment
and necessarily how that might evolve in
time so
what we what we hope to do with these
satellites is to take the data
combine these data with models and the
bringing the models and the the data
together gives us a real
nice 4d picture of what's happening now
and what's happened in the recent past
and that will allow us to really uh hone
and tune
the the information we've got about what
might happen in the future and that's
that's really critical
and that might be the future over the
next few days because a lot of people
working in the marine environment really
need that
but also obviously longer term for
climate change studies and so on
it's interesting isn't it because some
environmentalists actually quite opposed
to space travel they see it as hugely
expensive and actually in itself harmful
to the planet but this i suppose you
would argue is absolutely worthwhile
um how worried are you about the state
of our oceans
yeah i mean uh we have to be careful
there's all sorts of uh
things going on in the oceans that we
have to be very very aware of and
conscious of
the damage we're doing so of course sea
level rise as a as a result of
uh human induced uh climate changes is
is is a really big issue for
uh for the high impact events that we
get like flooding like storms and so on
uh they're they're they're a real issue
but there are other things there are
plastics in the ocean at the moment
and the the state of the marine and
marine ecosystems is something we really
uh got to keep an eye on because it's
under the under the sea people don't see
it but
you know we've we're really got to be a
bit more conscious about
how we treat the marine environment and
missions like this will allow us
um to understand the sea surface but
when you combine them with modeling and
uh and other surveys of the environment
we can really
make sure we're a bit more
do our duties as global sort of
assistance and better in the future i
think